ونتحول الى الصور مباشره الان من اسطنبول
لتجمع الجماهير لتحالف الجمهور
الذي يتكون من حزب العداله والتنميه وحزب
الحركه القوميه واحزاب اخرى هو التحالف
الحزب الحاكم في تركيا هذا مؤتمر جماهيري
لتحالف الجمهور ياتي بعد التحالف جماهير
اخر لتحالف الشعب المعارض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الرئيس التركي
وزوجته في هذا المؤتمر الجماهري رئيس
التركي سيلقي كلمه في هذا المؤتمر وطبعا
الانتخابات لم يبقى عليها الكثير وسيله
نعم بالفعل هذه الجماهير
لتحالف الجمهور وهو المكون من حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم وحزب الحركه القوميه كذلك
واحزاب اخرى وهذا يدخل ضمن مهرجانات
انتخابيه
تسبق هذه الانتخابات التي ستجرى بعد ايام
قليله ايام قليله بالفعل
التصويت في هذا الانتخابات بدا بالفعل
وسيله حوالين مليون ونصف
ناخذ تركي في خارج البلاد وفي المطارات
والمعابر ادلب باصواتهم بالفعل التصويت
مازال مفتوحا
للاطراك في المعابر وفي
المطاراتهم حتى يوم الرابع عشر من الشهر
الجاي وهو موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
تشهد
تنافس الرئيس
الطيب اردوغان عن تحالف الجمهور
والمعارضه الممثله بكمال الجدار اوغلو عن
تحالف الشعب الذي يمثل تعرف بالطاوله
بالسداسيه المعارضه طبعا اضافه الى رئيس
حزب البلد محرم انجا ومرشح تحالف الاجداد
[موسيقى]
طبعا هنالك جدل كثير حول تصريحات كلجدار
اوغلو تحدث فيها عن احتمال ان تلجا
السلطات الى تزييف بعض التسجيلات له
باستخدام ما سماه
الدارك نتس او الانترنت المظلم
للتزييف المظلم لتصريحات له
واثار هذا الموضوع جدلا كثيرا لان
التسجيلات
المزعومه تتحدث عن اتفاقات اجراها ولقاءات
اجراها مع حزب العمال الكردستاني الذي
طبعا ياخذوا حربا ضد الدوله التركيه نفسها
الان نستمع الى الرئيس التركيين
جمهور وفيها ارتقينا الى رئاسه الوزراء
فرئاسه الجمهوريه هذه المسيره كلها كانت
معكم وبكم
والان
ها نحن معكم في الطريق نفسه وفي الدرب
نفسه
مشينا هذه الطريق
معا هذه الغيوم كل الاغاني التي اسمعها
تذكرني بكم
ما شاء الله
ذوبوا حيث ثم جمدوها ودفنوها في التراب
فكانت اسطنبول هي شيء
ينبعث في نفسي الهواء
والاقليم
وكل شيء هي محبوبه التي تجاوزت حيز الزمان
والمكان
الشمس والقمر منذ الازل هما
منشاهما وبلدهما اسطنبول
البحر
والتراب في اسطنبول كانتا وفي اسطنبول
التقت الاحلام ورؤى
اسطنبول
هي روحي
ووطني الذي احب
اسطنبول اسطنبول ولا شيء الا اسطنبول
[تصفيق]
اسطنبول العزيزه
احييكم من صميم قلبي بكل الحب
يا لهذا الجمال
[تصفيق]
الطرق ملا بالناس
[موسيقى]
اسطنبول اليوم تهتف في الرابع عشر من مايو
سنجعل بعضهم
يذهب الى التقاعد تعرفون من هم صحيح
امس كانوا في ملطبه
نعم
الرقم الرسمي مليون و700 شخص هم الحضور
[تصفيق]
اسطنبول اوليس بها من طاقه ان تفعل ذلك
اوليست تستطيع ان تكتسح الصناديق رضي الله
عنكم جميعا
او ليس الشاعر يقول
الطريق اليه والبقاء له
كثيرا ما زحفت يا سكريا فانهضي على قدميك
الان اسطنبول تنهض على قدميها
اسطنبول
كل زقاق فيك وكل حي
وكل تله وهضبه احييها اذا نكره هذه الكلمه
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في مؤتمر
جماهري انتخابي قبل اسبوع من الانتخابات